so a couple days ago
25th amendment was trending on twitter
and considering the ongoing chaos that
is the bite administration right now
many people are still wondering if this
is the moment
that they finally hand off the mantle to
kamala harris because everybody expected
it you know even before the election
everybody was like how long is joe biden
going to last and then a bunch of people
said you know as much as i want to
believe he wouldn't last a term he'll
probably make it to the end of a term
and then maybe he won't run a second
term and then there was a period where
he said he wasn't gonna run a second
term and then he's like no no i'm gonna
run a second term and uh so now
you've got the white house chief of
staff not doing interviews kamala harris
not
you know saying she doesn't want to be
talking about this stuff joe biden does
one one interview where he apparently
lies left and right
and this is just i mean it's this
absolute chaos what we're seeing you've
got analysts coming out you've got
former military saying that here's what
could have been done in afghanistan they
don't understand how it's gotten so bad
so
is this the moment where joe biden
resigns in disgrace or they invoke the
25th amendment kamala hara steps up no
probably not uh and there's a new poll
showing that 55 percent of the country
believes she's unfit anyway
but then what nancy pelosi
then what i have no idea this is what
happens when people vote they didn't
vote for the lesser of two evils they
literally just voted against they didn't
vote for anything i'm like even when
you're voting for the lesser of two
evils you're still assuming that the
lesser is somewhat better for some
reason but joe biden wasn't he was
literally just a body the atlantic wrote
that article stay alive joe biden all we
need is your corporeal form so when
it's donald trump people said i will
take literally i'll take a ham sandwich
and what do you think happens when you
put a ham sandwich in charge of a
withdrawal from afghanistan joe biden
knew what he was getting into he said he
wanted to run for this so so we got
problems we'll talk about this though we
also got news on the vaccine front
obviously these mandates are spreading
they're hitting schools oregon now is is
mandating for teachers i'm getting
messages from teachers saying they're
going to be quitting i'm getting
messages from truck drivers saying
they're done because they're not going
to risk going into cities where they
can't use services or facilities unless
they have a vaccine
so it sounds like this is just a big
recipe for disaster but we'll get into
all this stuff we are hanging out with
delano squires how's it going man good
thank you for having me you want to
introduce yourself tell people what you
do sure um my name is delano squires i
am a contributor for the blaze regular
contributor on fearless with jason
whitlock
um
been writing for public consumption for
over 10 years started off with black and
married with kids
then went to the root in the griot a
couple years back
made a transition started writing for
the federalists
and now with the blaze also a scholar
with 17 17 1776 unites project
and um you know i'm a dad husband
homeschool dad
and um you know just like so the route
yeah to the blaze yeah it's a big jump
it is
probably the only person in the country
who can say they've written for the root
and the blaze but it's you know it's
it's because you learn right yeah yeah
and and i mean i think a lot of the
issues that we talk about are issues
that can be come at you know from a
number of different perspectives and
i'm i tend to write a lot about
family and faith and education and
social issues issues in the black
community but
trying to approach them oftentimes from
a biblical christian worldview so you
know that's my story cool right on man
it's very fun we got ian what's up
everybody ian crossland over here happy
to be here good to see you dog
thank you i'm in the corner pushing
buttons for this show as usual i'm
really excited for this conversation
because he's a homeschooling dad and we
don't get those very often so i'm stoked
to hear what he's got to say about the
world amazing i'm a big fan oh yeah
absolutely how old's the kid i got three
so our oldest is five and we have a
three-year-old and then we have a
one-year-old
so my wife is busy that's fine all day
nice yeah homeschooling though man i'm a
big big proponent well me too well we'll
get into it uh so before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up after the show usually goes up
on the website around 11 or so p.m as a
member you also get an advertisement for
experience and you're helping support
all of our fierce and independent
journalism we have no big billionaire
backers or anything like that our
backers are literally you guys who are
members and that has really rubbed the
mainstream media the wrong way because i
get these hit pieces where they're like
he has no support from the mercers or
the coax and i'm like i don't care
whatever we're gonna do our thing you
guys you guys are making it all happen
so greatly appreciated make sure you
smash that like button right now do it
for ian
please please and thank you
and uh subscribe to
the channel share the show with your
friends let's let's get into this let's
get into the failures of what's going on
and i'm not going to dwell too much on
the 25th amendment but i did pull this
article i find very funny it's from
vanity fairs hive they said republicans
who stood by a presidential lunatic are
now demanding biden be removed by the
25th amendment they were fine with trump
trying to overthrow the u.s government
but insist biden must go i really love
the framing because i i don't i don't
think anyone was fine with trump
overthrowing the government i think
that's just a very unfair way to look at
what was happening
but let's move forward to why joe
biden's being criticized in the first
place we're going to talk more about
what's going on with afghanistan
biden versus reality from the daily mail
president falsely stated that the u.s
has no troops in syria when there are
900 and the afghan military had 300 000
troops in a series of lies and bungled
statements in an abc interview biden
said there was no way to leave
afghanistan without chaos ensuing but
six weeks ago he said a taliban takeover
was highly unlikely he said the u.s
doesn't have a presence in syria but 900
troops remain the president took
questions from the media for the first
time in over a week on wednesday in an
interview with abc's george
stephanopoulos yeah but was he actually
making himself available to all press
in one bizarre moment biden seemingly
brushed off afghani stowaways so
desperate to flee they clung to
departing u.s plane before falling to
their death and now we've got the white
house chief of staff who apparently is
not doing interviews but is getting
criticized because he's tweeting a bunch
of far leftists on social media you've
got john sackey on vacation kamala
harris says i don't want to be talking
about this stuff
man what's going on with this
administration dude um
not enough but too much so that's a good
way to put it
i mean this week has been rough for the
body administration and just us as you
know as a country regardless of how you
feel about the war a lot of people feel
like you know
one we should have gotten out of there
but not in the way that we left and
certainly shouldn't uh have left people
who helped us
uh behind but even more importantly
definitely not leaving americans behind
so
um that's the craziest thing about it
yeah we've got 15 000 americans still in
afghanistan and this is one of the
things i kind of
you know when biden said that i think it
was biden who said this right in the in
the interview with with abc that there's
15 000 americans that are still there
they can't get them out because they
can't get to the airport and that kind
of like i had this moment where my heart
kind of went like bump them like big
because i was like
you know what's going to happen in the
next couple of months yeah the taliban's
not going to be like oh american right
this way well you're going to escort
forward they're going to be like on your
knees and we're going to start seeing
videos of this stuff
and then
yeah i agree i'm i'm i'm i'm hoping the
taliban is more scared
of losing any kind of international
recognition which i don't think they're
going to get in the first place and
considering the stuff we're already
seeing out of there it really does feel
like they might try to be like no no
americans we're we're being peaceful you
can go
but
i i don't see them getting the
recognition i guess one of the things
they're saying now is that the u.s has
accepted saudi arabia and they basically
want to do the same thing so what's the
problem
i don't know though you know i i think
there may be some hope in that they're
scared of the u.s still and so they're
like just get the americans out of here
but 15 000 how many of them might be
contractors yeah how many of them may
have crossed the taliban in some way and
they're gonna be like not this one and
then we start seeing these videos
so why didn't the biden administration
hard mandate evacuate americans before
the withdrawal you know they left bagram
air force base in the middle of the
night they just ran out left everything
wow the conspiracy theory is that they
wanted to make it such a poorly executed
withdrawal that it makes it makes people
want to go back like you see how
horrible it was that makes people want
to go back in later they're doing it
they're sending in more troops whether
or not it's intentional but it's really
really about dude watching the people
fall from the airplane was really really
guttural because i remember
watching the people fall from the world
trade center they were they were hanging
out the window and they jumped out
because they didn't want to burn to
death
and um it's like bookends
20 years
that's crazy dude yeah all to get osama
bin laden and they invaded the country
like what they obviously wasn't to get
osama bin laden they didn't have to
invade the country to do that yeah
someone should ask bush what's going on
huh there's a really great meme where
it's uh
three spider-man you know the two
spider-man meme yeah it's three and it
says you know like biden trump obama
they're all pointing at each other and
george w bush is painting the picture
yeah dick cheney really he was he ran
the military at that point but
halliburton his company what was his
role at the halliburton was either
chairman of the board or the ceo or
something yeah i'll give biden i'll give
mine this respect because he said it's
in a speech that he didn't want to pass
this this this failure off in the next
presidency because that's what obama did
obama obama got it from w bush and he
promised he was going to end all of this
stuff and instead we got more troops and
i think one of the big reasons was
he didn't want it to happen under his
name he didn't want the failure to be on
him he passes it off to trump trump says
okay we're drawing down i mean it wasn't
it was only it was it was bush obama
trump tru uh so obama receives the you
know he inherits this war
and then it just keeps going he keeps it
going trump inherits it and says we're
ending this now we should have ended it
a long time ago biden says you know what
i'll follow through
he screwed it up
bad
real bad so but but do you think obama
didn't want the failure to be on him or
do you think he was afraid that if he
pulled out of afghanistan we may end up
getting an attack on our soil so he'd
rather fight them there than than fight
them here i don't i don't believe that
because the there was this report came
out a long time ago that said one of the
contribut one of the main drivers of
terror in the us is what the cia called
blowback that the u.s operations in the
middle east over the past several
decades had created the anger and
animosity which resulted in so uh the
the targeting of the us so with like the
us funding of the mujahideen and then
meddling in these countries and iran and
things like that you end up with groups
saying they're going to come after us
staying in afghanistan
i suppose it makes sense though because
they're so preoccupied fighting us over
there they don't come over here yeah but
i think the i we had the patriot act we
buffed up our security we locked
everything down to still then be worried
about it just goes to show the security
measures were probably pointless yeah
well so so one thing that that this
entire
um
saga particularly over the last week has
made me think about and i hope it makes
other americans think about is that
democracy is not the natural order of
things
it's not everyone's default
it doesn't necessarily work in all parts
of the world at all times with all
people
and
i hope it's made americans rethink what
we call oppression
because real desperation looks like
somebody hanging on to the to the
landing gear of a cargo plane
from afghanistan to wherever they were
going
not you know some hollywood actress
who's pampered who you know somebody
writes the wrong name on their starbucks
cup and they say oh my gosh
or not some athlete who you know sees a
police shooting 4 000 miles away and
they don't have the facts and they say
oh my people are so oppressed
because when life really gets that
difficult
you see what
um desperation will drive people to and
i hope it makes us reassess how we use
language
i'm tired of living in hyperbole nation
where everything has to be
catastrophized it's like no we can we
can deal with our issues
without using the same words to describe
light inconveniences here that other
people use to describe actual tyranny
over there yeah absolutely dude right on
i mean so many people in this country
think that every slight offense is the
apocalypse they got to film it someone
someone said a naughty word to me on the
street it's like
in this country some dude was like
fleeing for his life and you know grip
to a plane yeah you wanna know this the
craziest thing about that
uh that dude on the plane he was 19
years old wow there are multiple people
yeah the two people who fell one of them
was a 19 year old kid from afghanistan
and you wanna know why that's crazy he's
younger than the war yeah he does not
know a world in which the taliban was
afghanistan he was born into this
country under us occupation he grows up
in that system and then overnight
overnight within a month it was it was
like a one-month collapse you saw this
going down
and then really escalated at the very
end of the past few days and all of a
sudden you've got islamic militants
something he doesn't understand and
never lived under saying
it's it's this or or or else
so he was like get me on that plane yeah
i'll take the orls
you know a lot of people pointed out
that
these are fighting age young men who
should have stayed and fought
and i think that's i think it's half
true it is true they're fighting age
young men they should have stayed and
fought the problem was you know i was
reading this op-ed they said a couple
things there's two different ones the
binding administration pulled air
support
as soon as they lost that was the
centerpiece of the military strategy so
the afghan security forces were like
what what do we do now we have no like
it was maintenance i guess we have no
way to maintain our air force because we
don't know how to do this and the other
was the aban they abandoned bagram like
overnight and so all of a sudden the
security forces are like waking up one
day with nothing and they're like uh
that was like an abrupt massive shift
overnight yeah so all of a sudden
they're overrun they don't got the ammo
they've got the support
yeah
these people do not care about civilian
life they don't even care about their
own military military life they got us
into a war recklessly and got us out of
the war recklessly so many hundreds of
thousands of people have died their
families have been tarnished
this 19 year old kid probably knows
somebody that
i think it's for money i think it's for
for for opium i think that's why they
did that is for drugs and uh
oil i wouldn't i don't think it's i
wouldn't make it so specific i just say
power that opium trade all of that stuff
was just but i don't blew up in the last
two decades the opium i i agree but the
way i would phrase it is i don't think
they're looking at their their like you
know their their
bottom line in calculating opium i think
they're just like what's the money right
you know who i don't care what person is
worth a hundred grand each or we'll be
civil ped peds civilians pet ants are
worth
60 grand each so if we kill 3 000 of
them that's
you know 1.8 million but we're going to
make 60 million in heroin
so easily that's a good deal for us plus
all the opportunity cost that's gone
when you don't have to feed people i
mean it's terrifying that's what
governments have been doing is deciding
who lives and who dies and but they
they're so when they become aggressive
then they create such things where they
have to make that choice but they
created that situation
i could
this is like a deep spiral and the
madness for me i'm i'm i mean i
i don't we're out though you know what i
mean so as much as i can be really upset
with the images we're seeing and now the
potential of these 15 000 americans i
still think it was right to get the
troops out and so
it's it's it's a challenge because if
you knew beforehand that biden was a
[ __ ] and we did
and that this would probably be
seriously screwed up and we could all
assume that
would we still do it
and
i think the answer is yes however
i think there would have been
there there had to have been some kind
of i don't know man
how did he not listen to any like his
intelligence was bad the admit it's
chaos
so
it's a tough question yeah everything
we're seeing right now i'm curious as to
how
um this experience in in the last 20
years
how they will reshape
our politics both domestically and our
foreign policy
i'm curious as to
you know what america's role on the
national stage
what role we want to take in terms of
nation building
you know as the world's policeman i
wonder what the appetite will be for
that from either political party
um
i i think this could be the beginning of
the end
we got we got what like 25k troops in
korea or you know a certain amount in
japan we got soldiers in germany how
long until the this
all this we're seeing results in
americans just being like we shouldn't
be doing this um what if so if we really
do see like a red wave backlash to biden
that results in trump coming back in or
someone like trump and their trump was
saying get our troops out of germany
like why do we got troops in germany
that makes no sense germany's fine they
can handle their own security
what happens when we get a trump was
just like how many of you think we
should be focused on america first yeah
and then you get people just screaming
yes because we're sick of this foreign
foreign intervention stuff yeah
and then what happens
i don't know because i mean it's easy to
say that you bring the troops home
everybody says yes we can focus on our
domestic problems but as you see
whether it's the influence of
china or other countries growing in
other areas people start to say okay
these other countries are not doing the
same thing they are definitely
globalists they want to control parts of
africa and the caribbean
latin america what is america going to
do and how would we feel as a country if
um
china let's say china's influence grows
to the point where
they are basically everywhere but
you know mexico us and canada is that
something that our politicians would
want to live with um it's easy to talk
about you know sort of a
non-intervention as a
you know political exercise but again
when you see the influence of those
countries growing whether china or
russia whoever it is
is that something that we can live with
this is the this is the big challenge
yeah so i'm i'm i usually err on the
side of anti-intervention but we should
mind our own business we should be
building up roads in america we should
do these things because those are the
first the immediate
and the obvious you know um you know
problems to address
but then i'll remind everybody you know
and i'm not i'm not trying to say it's
right to invade other countries not at
all but keep in mind
when during the during the cold war you
had the expansion of communism this is
this is despotic authoritarianism they
were massacring people i mean
you look at what's going on what
happened in cambodia you look at what
happened in in southeast asia all across
these countries it was a nightmare
and so the u.s was their their mentality
it wasn't just blindly like we're going
to go to armani it was like if we sit
back
and the communists
keep expanding because they're
militaristic they're taking over
in 20 30 years it will be impossible to
stop them we either confront them now
or in 30 to 40 years they surround us on
all sides
look at us and say now you're done and
then they control our trade they control
they influence us and then we fall to
them so the americans they want to do it
now with afghanistan it's not the same
thing it's it's not like china's
literally gonna you know
it's not like you know communist
russia's massive expansion but china
does
they are working with the belt and road
initiative they are expanding so it's
probably more strategic and therein lies
the scary question
if the us doesn't have any kind of
international presence
do we just wait until china surrounds us
so so ultimately just one more final
point to that the u.s was expanding and
surrounding everybody else they viewed
us the way we view them right now
interesting
the the way you described it
as you were talking about you know
um russia's expansion
i said that's the cultural world we're
fighting
um the the groups that are influenced by
you know marxism and leftism of one sort
or another
are always looking for territory to
capture yep
and unless
you know there's pushback from everyday
citizens and and a lot of people look to
the republican party i don't know that
they are astute enough to understand the
game that's being played i say that
because oftentimes they mouth the same
slogans
they they chant the same things they
seem to have the same worldview they
don't understand how they're being used
and unless
there is a pushback in 20 30 years
there will be no space left everybody
will either have to be you know trading
bitcoin and and doing uncancelable jobs
right so if you
you know if you trade options or if you
are
investing
it doesn't really matter what your
politics are
but if you have a job in the private
sector and you're one of the people who
says no i don't want to fly the flag i
don't want to put up the the state
party's uh official slogan you're going
to find life very very difficult for
yourself that's a good point actually
trading you know because it's just you
log in but then what happens when your
bank bans you that's true when your you
know credit card shuts down and or your
social credit score drops below a
certain level
yeah i mean conservatives better start
opening some banks and libertarians yeah
so
i think indicative of a vulnerability in
the system of centralized banking that
any one person would ever have the power
to stop other people from banking yeah i
think this is where the vaccine
passports are going social credit scores
i think so too let me pull up this story
we got from the new york times
this is it cdc data right now vaccine
effectiveness against infection may wane
cdc studies fines federal health
officials said the new data justified a
campaign of booster shots but some
scientists disagreed saying not every
american needs another dose
what's the problem
it's just a vaccine right hmm why are
you mad ian it's just a little piece of
paper you already got it you might as
well just show it to him well
who cares it's just an app you've
already got a phone with that app just
it's just a booster shot to your doctor
it's just a booster shot okay look there
were four lines on it from the beginning
what's wrong with the second booster
shot got to get boosted
look look some of these people who who
are not vaccinated are spreading covets
so we set up a quarantine zone
what's wrong with the quarantine zone
it's just a camp for people that's
that's that's the way things roll oh
yeah so in australia
you know they're building the quarantine
hub in uh in the u.s last year the cdc
announced shielding we did we have
talked talked about it before we didn't
talk about it last show and then people
reminded us the that the cdc proposed
their shielding plan which would create
camps
for people who are at risk
it's like pretty sure the unvaccinated
people are at risk i mean look if you
talk to your doctor about what makes
sense for you but i think i honestly
don't think the vaccine passports are
really what it's all about
i think it's about getting you to
download the app and then them having
the tracking and requiring the id for
you to get into a building interesting
you get your smart id things coming up
with those rfid chips on it i definitely
think they're trying to centralize and
control and um
spy on is that the right word observe
your behavior they are so that you can't
commit crimes bro your phone is spying
on everything you do man that's crazy
yeah it's really weird and they can lit
i mean
the satellite tech is getting really
good too they can listen to you through
from space wow listen through your walls
and stuff
i don't know if that's common but with
lasers maybe yeah i don't know what what
uh what kind of radio waves they fire
well so so look i'll say it again
um we've had a lot of conservatives on
the show and the media accused them all
of being antibiotics it's not true a
good portion of them have been
vaccinated and talk about why they
thought it was a good idea for them many
of them are having to be older so you go
and talk to your doctor and you figure
it out and we had we had kurt schlichter
on the show his doctor was conservative
he talked to him in one of the numbers
he made he made the choice for him and
that's what i'm all about i'm about
informed consent
but now we're being told it's gotta have
booster shots right so when you combine
that with the four cities that are doing
the vaccine mandates
and with the boosters
i think they're saying now that with the
booster the effectiveness goes back up
to like 84 or whatever
is this going to be a never-ending thing
now where it's not just a vaccine
passport
it's your up-to-date medical card
because what else once you open the door
to that
asking for your id and for proof of some
kind of medical history at what point do
they just start adding more and more
things to it like outside it doesn't
make sense because if it's a virus
that's mutating and it's also in the
animal population
and you can't kill it with a vaccine so
why would you why would you chase
trying to kill something you can't kill
it doesn't make any sense
well i guess some people were saying
that although there there are animal
reservoirs for kovid they haven't
transferred back into humans i don't
know if that's true that's just one of
the arguments i saw online
but we can just say this i mean variants
are like dr fauci has been all over the
place all over the place how can we
track what we're supposed to do it's
like hey youtube i'm trying to be a good
little youtuber here i want to make sure
people are safe i don't want to give
medical advice what am i supposed to do
when voucher comes out every other day
with something different yeah i just saw
an article from the new york times says
those anti-covered
plastic barriers probably don't help and
they make things worse and they were
saying it forces the air to like
stagnate and then the viral load
increases because the air is not
circulating yeah
what weren't they saying
weren't they saying before that it was
like on surfaces and they said it wasn't
on surfaces yeah yeah
and i think a lot of people particularly
early on said you know what we're still
learning about covid
we give the government some leeway
you know the guidance changes
we you know we want to trust our public
officials
i told my friends
once the public health officials decided
that
um 10 000 people in the town square to
protest
over you know the george floyd incident
or racial injustice generally speaking
once they decided that was okay
but a church couldn't meet outdoors and
its 50 members couldn't meet outdoors
the game was lost and nobody would ever
trust either the elected officials or
the public health bureaucrats because it
was clear that they were using this
virus um for partisan means one to get
obviously to get trump out of office and
two
to um
you know sort of bring onto themselves a
certain power that obviously they don't
want to give up and you could see that
hypocrisy all throughout last year
people saying you know kids can't go to
school but their kids are having in
in-person instruction in private schools
yeah you know
saying again you you can't meet you
shouldn't get together with your family
for thanksgiving or christmas
but
you know them allowing you know people
as i said to cram the public square
so i'll say this
last year
i want to say it was august
the church i was going to in dc
sued the city
to allow it to meet outdoors
socially distant mast on his own
property
and they weren't allowed to do so
at the same time
the city issued a permit
for
the sort of march on washington where
they had like 10 000 people you know
downtown and when i saw that i was like
nobody's going to listen to these people
anymore and i think
once the public health officials and the
elected officials
who constantly flouted their own rules
once that became public they lost the
most precious thing that they needed to
manage this pandemic which is trust and
i don't think they'll ever get it back
again it's it's true but if you look at
new york right now man these businesses
are saying you know we're just following
orders they're gonna do it yeah and and
i i mentioned this before i'll say it a
million times because this is one of the
craziest things i've i've never thought
i'd see something like this bill de
blasio's mandate means
every business in new york must
terminate any employee who has a
disability barring them from getting
vaccinated and there's a lot there's a
lot of different you know
illnesses or ailments or disabilities
you could have that make it impossible
for you to get this yeah you're fired
yeah that that this is this is fascistic
beyond all recognition
so
i think a lot of people have seen what
was going on and they and they want to
say no to this so in many areas they
probably are just saying like i'm not
going to do it.
but you look at new york and people
after all of this are still just saying
well i'll do whatever the mayor says
yeah yeah people are starting to revolt
in france did you guys see any of that
video oh have you seen the videos though
where like the cops are walking up to
people at the restaurants or when they
try to go to a supermarket now they're
being barred from going in a supermarket
yeah and then i saw one where the crowd
was rising up and yelling at the cops
yeah there was no blows struck but
it's getting hot and it's just getting
started yeah and i think um again i'm
i'm trying to think about long term
what this political realignment can look
like right so for a lot of conservatives
who may not have been as open to
um
assertions from their left
that the police are heavy-handed and
particularly in communities of color
they are getting a taste of what that
feels like
so when you're at a game and you're
supposed to be masked outdoors and
you're not and the cops come and enforce
it and you say i don't want to wear a
mask and then next thing you know you're
on the ground and being tased
now you can get a sense of what other
people were saying and i think what
you're going to end up seeing is sort of
a a
coalition building
of folks on the right who are typically
pro-police
but are
definitely anti-government
lockdowns and mandates
along with
you know folks who may be on the center
left who say the police have had
expanding powers and too much authority
for a lot of years and i think you're
going to see that coalition start to
form pretty soon i think so we did see
uh uh we did see a little bit of the
right pushing back on cops at the height
of the lockdowns last year you had uh i
think nypd were refusing to enforce
lockdowns so they brought in troopers
there was a guy at a bar he was open but
giving things away for free they're like
we don't care they they blocked the
entrance and you had a lot of uh you had
videos of some conservatives throwing
the the thin blue line flag on the
ground and then stomping on it in the
dirt in front of cops yeah they weren't
having it all of a sudden churches were
being shut down cops were defending it
yeah you had the mayor of new york
paying black lives matter in the street
without approval from the city just
taxpayer money and 27 cops defending it
and so that's all okay and they were
arresting people who protested it yeah
so eventually i think
you know maybe maybe it's uh a cold
wake-up call to a lot of uh people on
the right that cops will just follow the
orders yeah yeah you know michael malus
has a pretty bold we'll just call it
bold quote where he said they're
i'm going to paraphrase this i don't
know specifically but there is no law
so depraved a cop will not enforce it up
and uh up and uh to
executing innocent children
now that's michael malus it's a very
very
bulletin because i'm i don't necessarily
agree like i kind of think a cop is
going to be like i'm not going to
experience soviet union experience
personal experience and so i think i
think what people need to realize is
you're look you're thinking about a cop
right now
a cop right now is not gonna do it he's
gonna be like get out of here dude are
you crazy like come on we got a line but
a cop in five ten years when the good
cops get purged out when they mandate
vaccines for everybody and then you
start getting skeptics and hesitant
people or people with disabilities being
like i don't know about that when the
military says it and now you've got
whether or not people are right or wrong
in their decision to make a decision and
the military says bye you're out of the
military now you've got an increasingly
woke authoritarian kind of military yeah
then you will get a cop who will gladly
enforce because it's not what michael
malus is saying is the way i interpret
is it's not about cops as the individual
it's about the institution and what they
will come to represent should things get
that to that point
i hope we don't get there no we lived in
the armed society it'd be very very
unlikely that the police would throw
themselves in into that they've been
trying to take our guns
i love it yeah which is what
conservatives say this you know they'll
say look at the head of the fbi the
knight behind the atf
you know he wants to ban ar-15s and
anything with a capacity over 10 rounds
and
that's
i think
i've learned a lot
um
and have to have had to go back and and
rethink what it means to be an american
what our founding documents mean
um what the second amendment means right
i get people say for hunting and
and
self-defense i get it
but
tyranny really is not something we've
had to think about as a country
legitimately for for a pretty long time
and and as i said
the the
on on the left
tyranny and particularly and i'm
thinking you know particularly you know
in african american community we'll say
you know police brutality
police overreach
tyranny to us is
assault on our physical bodies
for conservatives a lot of time tyranny
means the irs is coming after me it's
very different
um
i think we're starting to see
more people wake up and say you know
what the government is inserting itself
into our personal health decisions
it is trying to control how we educate
our children um it is trying to control
whether and how and where we make a
living
and eventually people are going to get
tired of that and the same military
folks who may get purged that's how you
get people who are disaffected and
become more radical than they otherwise
would have been yeah um if if our
government would just let us live like
free people well speaking of what's
going on in politics and you know uh
elaborating on this segment we have an
article here from the
blaze will joe biden and ibram kendy
save novak's blacks from jab crow
attacks donald squires so but but this
is the general idea i guess is around
like vote uh around voter id being
racist but now they're demanding ids in
new york do you want to just let it tell
us what the article's about which sure
sure so
it um articles about a couple things one
i started off thinking about ibram kendy
and his assertion that any policy that
produces
um disparate or or inequitable
outcomes is in and of itself racial uh
racist so if there's a particular public
policy and it impacts black people more
than whites and asians then that policy
is racist but then i also thought about
how joe biden at one point called a
proposed law in georgia that would
require among other things would require
and a valid id to vote by mail
he said that that law made
jim crow look like jim eagle and i said
oh okay so i could see these two
partnering up and saying that vaccine
passports
particularly the new york city policy
pushed by de blasio
which
um which would have a a disproportionate
effect on black communities because only
as less than 40 of black new yorkers are
actually vaccinated
um i expect ibram kennedy and joe biden
to both say that jab crow
is totally unacceptable in america and
20 20 million
and that
this policy that is going to produce
disparate you know racial outcomes is in
and of itself racist right and ibra
candy if he did that
that would mean he would be calling some
of his biggest supporters on the left
racist the people who are pushing us
um and i'm just curious as to whether or
not these two will stand on principle
um or whether they will sacrifice
you know their sacred cow of racial
equity come on on the altar of political
pragmatism i'm not going to come out and
say anything no
i love the jab crow though that was that
was brilliant you know but joe biden
might but he might not um
not legitimately what might happen is
because of the backlash he might then be
like oh yeah well you know we're always
saying id you can't do that so in this
instance if there's enough outrage
then he might just find it as an excuse
to be like oh here's why i post it's not
about vaccines you know he can save face
in that regard right and say oh i am for
people getting the vaccine and you know
wanting to have that security but you
know we can't have ids to get in
buildings yeah but see but but i think
part of the issue and this is why you
see the media pushing
the narrative of the unvaccinated being
white evangelical trump voters because
they don't want to tell the truth which
is
nationally again
um black americans have lower rates of
vaccination than other groups but if
they can make uh vaccination into a
a white evangelical conservative issue
then it's a lot more palatable for
people
um to say we want to enforce vaccination
with vaccine passports this is crazy too
because for a long time they were saying
they wanted to roll out the vaccine
program based on race yeah they wanted
minorities to get access first because
they were under vaccinated and people
were like that that to me was kind of a
so i'm i'm i'm very much
philosophically behind universal
healthcare i just don't know if we can
possibly do it right that's the big
challenge but the idea that someone that
we could we could pay lower rates save
trillions of dollars because everybody's
pitching into a functioning system it
sounds brilliant right until you learn
that what does the government do once
they have the ability to regulate health
they do it based on race
no i i i don't think that's a good idea
to give the power to the government when
they do things like that
um
so one of the things i talk about an
article right
is
you know when i get serious and i get
past the sort of tongue and cheek stuff
about jab crow is
this is actually a perfect example
of why ibram kenny's philosophy of
anti-racism and
racial equity will never work because
what you've seen in this rollout is to
your point whether people agree with it
or not an emphasis on
um
providing vaccine access to low-income
black and hispanic communities
all out public awareness campaigns to
get those communities vaccinated
making the vaccine free to everyone
putting you know vaccine centers right
in the heart of communities in the
neighborhood i was living in in dc there
was one by the grocery store there cvs
is all over the place and you still see
um different rates by group in terms of
vaccination so one of the things i talk
about is a principle i call it squash
principle because that's what people do
they name stuff after themselves
and um
it's fairly simple
the premise is this
that government control has a direct
relationship with
the perceived success of any policy but
individual agency has an inverse
relationship because the government is
good at certain things the government
can say we want to build new rec centers
in all the low-income neighborhoods they
have the resources they have the
political will
um they can do that what they can't do
is guarantee that we're going to
reduce diabetes and hypertension by 75
because that has to do with how people
eat how they exercise
and and how they rest now they can do
things on the periphery but ultimately
the more policy requires individual
agency
um the less successful is going to be
from the government's perspective well
so so
you still have the black community
less vaccinated than other racial
demographics even with all of these
programs correct
so there's no policy solution is there
it's a it's cultural or or what is it
part of it and i know people who work in
government don't like to hear this but
sometimes people don't want the things
that you want to give them for one
reason or the other because as adults as
rational adults people make decisions
they may say the risk of me
getting covert in a serious bout of
covid and you know the worst type of
symptoms is not worth me
you know taking this particular vaccine
now we may agree with the decision or
not but it's their decision but that's
something that the left has a hard time
with right they think if we think it's
social good everybody else should and
instead of trying to
persuade
um
be honest about facts answer questions
honestly
you know
take a nuanced approach
they say you know what we're done with
the error of persuasion we're into
coercion and force and that's what the
vaccine passport is that was a good
point you made about how if they feel as
a social good everyone else must as well
it's bigger than that it's that they
believe their world view is the same
within every single person yes and so to
them here's here's one i have to bring
up which plays your point as well
if i was given a free place to live i'd
take it therefore all homeless people
need only be given a free place to live
and homelessness is solved right except
i've worked with homeless shelters and
you know you know you know what you get
most of the time when you go to homeless
person offer my shelter so no
sir we have a vehicle waiting for you
right here and they're like i got stuff
i got friends right this is where i live
right i don't know you i don't want to
be anywhere near you i don't care about
your house you know people who are used
to living outside are not
you know i guess you've got young people
they're naive
and they must genuinely believe like
well who wouldn't want to have a bed to
sleep in some people like their sleeping
bag under a bridge i'm not exaggerating
i'm not saying it's a good thing but
they that's what they know that's what
they're used to and they feel safe there
and so the left just assumes every
homeless person is actually just a down
on their luck you know out of work laid
off guy holding a sign saying we'll work
for food lack of affordable housing
right
and so the solutions they often offer up
are hey how about we put vaccination
centers in all the black neighborhoods
that way they'll get vaccinated and then
they don't because they're not actually
addressing the community's needs or or
desires in any meaningful way other than
just some bland policy position that
doesn't solve the problem yeah it's not
it's not like it's a black person white
person thing they horribly guffed this
whole covet experience for every human
that i don't think it's a racial has
anything to do with race about how we
are questioning i do think that like
look it's a critical thought maybe maybe
that's is that inherent in the black
community critical thought like critical
it's a joke i don't know we're
genetically different but like critical
but like no no not that different i i
think race plays an obvious role in um
how communities form we see it with
immigration
people choose to move to areas where
like you know you end up with a
chinatown you end up with a little italy
yeah maybe maybe it's not maybe race
isn't not the right word maybe that's
the city it's not race yeah we're the
same race or its culture is probably a
better like familiarity probably is a
better way to put it yeah so so i know
in the beginning a lot of the talk
around quote-unquote vaccine hesitancy
was around
you know you saw articles on the
tuskegee experiment and the history of
black communities with the healthcare
professions i'm not saying some of that
doesn't exist right
but again people make decisions for all
types of reasons i don't think every
black person who doesn't want to get the
shot is doing it because of the tuskegee
i don't think they're doing it because
they don't have access to it some people
just say i don't want it but for
whatever reason
that's an answer that some of our
elected officials just
cannot stomach they they won't allow it
no these people they must be vaccinated
and that's why you see
um actually this morning this was going
around on twitter ari melber was quoting
the notorious b.i.g
um a song from way back he was talking
about you know what's beef and talking
about you end up in the icu and ari
melbourne was trying to link that to not
getting the shot because if you don't
get the shot and you get covered you may
end up in icu and a lot of people you
know who i follow on social media were
like what is this guy talking about i
mean it was bad
you know to appropriate biggie's lyrics
to push you know your particular agenda
is not something that is going to
convince anyone so
again i can't answer for why everyone
chooses not to do it but to your point
people should consult their medical
professionals and they can they should
make a decision that makes sense for
them i agree with you i don't think most
of the problems that we talk about as
racial problems are racial problems
i come again i come with a with a
biblical worldview i believe there's
there's one race
many ethnicities many nationalities um
but
in our country we that's the way we tend
to think about things and i think people
like ibrahim candy have made that
even worse and that's why
it was a shot at him sort of
tongue-in-cheek i just want to see if
he's going to stand on his own
principles
my guess is that he won't yeah i'd agree
with that i'd make a gentleman's bet
it's an industry to protect yeah
yeah yeah the grievous industrial
complex yeah that's good did you come
over there
i like that one other people say it but
i was saying it before they said that's
right that's a good one too grievous
industrial complex man that's that's big
yeah we have critical race applied
principles well now that's pretty good
oh yeah absolutely have you heard that
one critical race applied principles i
have not that's actually one of our
super chatters said that so
so you know in schools it's critical
race practice yeah when they put the
theory into practice practice and i'm
like we need an a in there
for the actor
and someone said critical race applied
principles yes and we are like yeah
that's good
we have the story though let's talk
about how it's going to hit schools
we got this from fox 12 oregon brown
announces covet 19 vaccine vaccine
mandate for oregon k-12 teachers and
staff
k-12 school employees in oregon must be
fully vaccinated by the fall and
healthcare workers will no longer be
able to test for covet-19 weekly as a
vaccine alternative so there's a couple
of things here that are big one they
used to say if you get if you don't have
the vaccine you can get a negative test
now that's gone you can't do it
i also don't believe that there are
medical exemptions in any of these
which means teachers who have underlying
condition you're gone wow
so this is uh now affecting our schools
and that means
what's gonna happen are parents gonna
take their kids out of schools some
i mean you you've across the country
you've seen an uptick in homeschooling
across the board um i think you're going
to see that continue because
again last year
we were all dealing with covet everybody
sort of went through their stages there
was a period of time where people were
sanitizing their groceries when they
came from the store
but now i think we have a better sense
of the the virus we have a better sense
of the tip the different treatment
options
i don't think parents are going to stand
for another year of
um distance learning
universal masking mask mandates
vaccine mandates so i think some parents
are going to pull their kids out some
are going to stay and fight
it's interesting that this is oregon i
think
their governor
just relaxed some of the graduation
requirements in terms of literacy and
numeracy
in the name of equity
again it's always in the name of of
equity and um this doesn't surprise me
in the least bit but it's so curious and
i try not to be a conspiracy theorist
but when you see
the emphasis on our covert response
being basically one of two things
mass and vaccines
where's the discussion of you know
longer term solutions you know diet
exercise other you know healthier
lifestyles therapeutics different
treatment options
it's as if
the elected officials and the
commentators think it's either you wear
your mask you get vaccinated or you're
going to end up in icu and you're going
to die and i feel that's a really bad
way to have this discussion nationally
there was there's a crazy threat on
twitter where some some person claiming
to be a pharmacist i don't know if they
were said that they refused to fill a
prescription for ivermectin
and they didn't know what the
prescription was for
apparently and then they said they
called they called the doctor to verify
and the doctor said you know i'm the
doctor you're the pharmacist you fill it
and again i'll say ivermectin's not fda
approved it's going through studies some
people are optimistic some people aren't
there's studies that say it does nothing
ultimately i just think you which doctor
prescribes man i'm not going to get in
the way of that so so it's not fda
approved go to your doctor you can talk
about what you can do but to see people
on twitter as pharmacists or at least
claiming to be saying that they would
reject any prescription they disagreed
with i was like man didn't we have this
conversation long ago about birth
control
where the pharmacists were like it's
against my religion to give this out so
i'm choosing not to and then they were
yelled at for it
i think if a doctor says he knows what's
best for you i'm not going to get in the
middle of that yeah but these schools
man
to go back to that
i actually think this is a really really
good thing i think the more people we
have homeschooled the better i think
institutionalized learning facilities
are very very bad and so this might
backfire on these these government
institutions in that parents might just
say
what can we do to solve this problem
yeah the school's just getting crazier
and crazier yeah pod learning
you you've heard about like the pods
they do where like you know a bunch of
neighbors will have their kids go to
like one private tutor who will teach
them that sounds brilliant
but you're you're a big homeschool
proponent yeah so tell me about my wife
and i homeschooled um we had our
daughter at a in a public charter school
for about a year in d.c we decided to go
in a different direction
we love the flexibility that it offers
we love the the
we love the ability to make our home
the center of productive activity
productive economic activity spiritual
activity so
you know the ability to spend quality
time with our children particularly when
they're young to pour into them our
values our worldview
and to really teach them because we
believe that education is equal part
scholarship and discipleship
and when you look at the left and some
of the crazy things that go on in
schools i think every parent should ask
themselves do i want these people
discipline my kids um so i think you
know again i'm a huge fan a huge
proponent of home education
um for very principled reasons because
i think this is this is where the right
gets it wrong on school choice right i
believe in school choice
um i think education is the
responsibility of parents they may
delegate their responsibility to to
schools right in local parents but the
schools think in local parents is
spanish you know they think it means
these parents are crazy so it's our turn
to take over as opposed to latin which
means in place of parents
and i think parents need to take
that authority back and they need to
understand that they are in control of
the education process and not and not
the schools and the admins which are
becoming increasingly partisan
from the schools of education that train
teachers
to the actual admins on the local level
down to the the classrooms where
teachers are
expressly saying
we we are
looking to train you know the next
generation of activists and for me when
i look at a lot of these larger urban
school districts that in many respects
honestly are failing our kids and
particularly low-income kids
i'm asking myself you know what's the
point of
you know helping jamal be an activist if
he needs karen to write a sign you know
so to me again as i said this is where
parents can take some control but in
order to do that
we need to talk about other issues and
some of those have to do with family and
family formation my wife and i can do
what we're doing now because we're
married
you're right we have our kids together
we are pulling in the same direction but
homeschooling may may be a lot more
difficult for a single mom who's raising
her kids if she has to go out and work
so i think that's where community
institutions can come in um churches or
other you know faith-based institutions
can say
you know we have a couple of educators
on staff you all can bring your kids
here we'll we'll teach them in whatever
curriculum we think is the best and we
can support you know families in that
way churches man uh i i think a lot of
people who might have you know not grown
up with religion don't understand the
power of a church in in the sense of
you see people
and that's really yeah i mean you go
there and then you see your neighbors
and you know my experience is always
like people would be talking before and
after you needed help with something
people would be there for you yeah some
young men would you know some dad would
be like oh my kids will help you clean
out your garage you want your boys and
they'll be like yeah and then they'll go
and so you have that community now what
do we have is we have neighbors who
never talk to each other yeah we have
this there was this ad i don't know if
it's real i just saw meme and it's like
it's like a new york subway or something
where it says bad and it shows two faces
talking to each other then it says
uh
it says like worse and then it says
better and then it shows two people
wearing masks talking to each other and
then says best and it's two faces
looking down not talking to each other
at all one on a book one on the phone
and i'm like that's a nightmare yeah you
know so our buddy luke who's been on the
show quite a bit he made a video uh a
long time ago on his youtube channel
where uh i think it's called just keep
going got nothing to lose where he said
you know he's lived in new york his
whole life and every day he goes on the
train and he realized that none of these
people ever talk to each other no they
would look at each other so everybody's
head is down so we decided just to start
talking to people and asking them
questions about like what they think and
it's like a really moving video like a
million views and this is back in the
day so it did really really well but
that's a really good example of you know
when when when you're trying to figure
out how to teach your kids
family structure because if you don't
have two parents
or someone's a single mom can't do it
she can't afford a tutor either she
might not make it enough unless she's a
single mom and she's got a really
great job which probably exists in which
case pods
yeah fine you know hire a tutor yeah
have all the kids sit in a classroom
like normal yeah so so i actually um i
wrote an article for the blaze last week
that talked about you know family in
this way it talked about
it actually linked together a story
about nick cannon and his views on
marriage being eurocentric yep
um critical race theory and some of the
crazy stuff going on in schools and then
covet because
imagine you're a woman who's about to
have you know
either you've you've had a child
recently or you're looking to go back to
work
and your employer is saying
you know you have to take the vaccine so
if you're pregnant you're like i don't
know if i want to take it
feeling the pressure to take the vaccine
or lose your job potentially um
that's that's a that's a pretty
difficult decision to make and the point
i was making an article is that
you know when when couples again have
the benefit of marriage where
you know that they are
as i said pulling together in the same
direction for their
mutual benefit and the benefit of their
children it gives them options
you know a wife could tell her husband i
i don't want to do this
you know i'm tired of whatever's going
on at my workplace
for one reason or the other and and they
have options that you know other other
families don't have so i was making you
know the case for
marriage as as not just a social good
but also
you know a very sort of practical
arrangement that's not typically how i
make the case about marriage but it also
does have practical benefits and i think
you've seen that during the pandemic and
we have a lot of activists who want to
disrupt that yeah that was one of the
messages from black lives matter tell me
about don't get me started
i'm trying to get you started on that
why it seems so destructive yeah to hurt
a family yeah i mean part of it
when at the point where black lives
matter said that we are trained marxists
people should have listened to them
yep i thought you were going to say they
should have shut them out no you're
right they should have listened to them
they should have done that too yeah but
that's why i'm i'm a big believer in
world view
regardless of what it is you should know
what a person believes because that
that'll give you an understanding of why
they believe what they believe
so when marx talks about abolishing the
family because he understood that the
family is not just where children you
know receive their moral instruction but
is also a vehicle for passing down
private property um and he wanted he
wanted to take the kids from
their parents
and
dedicate them to the state right so
black lives matter
you know has a similar vision in in
their black villages principle before
they took it off their website because
they started to get a lot of heat for it
they talked about wanting to disrupt the
nuclear family requirement that you know
requires mothers to do x y and z
at no point do they talk about
fathers or husbands
um because in their world those people
don't exist and that's why i would make
an argument that you know blm is only
interested in black men to the extent
that their you know dead bodies help
further their political goals and that's
not the type of organization i would
there's there's under no circumstance
would i as a black man get behind any
organization that says that they want to
disrupt the nuclear family at all
they removed it though didn't they take
it off their website they got a lot of
heat but they had their principles on
their website for years
and once they started to grow in
prominence last year and people started
to pick up on it
and and some people would ask them
questions particularly on the
conservative media side
um you now they never got
asked questions from don lemon or roland
martin or any of the other media that
they did
you know sort of the corporate
legacy media
but once they started to get those
questions they scrubbed it because they
knew that that was a very very unpopular
take but i think people should
understand
that that organization
you know
those those principles were a reflection
of their world view and that's why i
asked people all the time if you started
an environmental organization and then i
go to your principles and you never
mention the environment that should be a
red flag so when you say you're against
police violence and in your 13
principles
you never mentioned police violence
men boys
it's all about you know
being queer affirming transgender
affirming women affirming
black families in black villages that
erase husbands and and fathers that
should have been a red flag to people
but for whatever reason
you know our our society just they take
whatever the top line is and they run
with it yep corporations yeah they said
hey this is safe what's wrong with that
yeah and you get a bunch of people
living in new york city who run who work
for advertising firms so they're the
ones who make those decisions yeah yeah
you see how that ended up let's swing it
back to schools real quick because we
have this story that's been going around
utah teacher no longer employed after
advocating vaccination and telling
students she hates trump alpine school
district said that kind of behavior will
not be tolerated the video of her
sharing her opinions in front of a class
at lehigh high school on tuesday was
shared widely on social media and by
wednesday morning the second day of the
new school year alpine school district
in utah county confirmed she wasn't
employed there anymore spokesman david
stevenson said in a statement that he
cannot comment on personnel matters and
would not say whether the teacher was
fired only that she wasn't working there
now she had originally originally been
put on leave tuesday while the district
investigated quote this behavior is
inappropriate not reflective of the
professional conduct and decorum we
expect of our teachers and will not be
tolerated
have you seen the video i haven't i've
seen people sharing i didn't get a
chance to to watch it
i uh
i don't agree with this i i would have
loved to have been in that class i
watched this video she wasn't screaming
at people
she was just giving her opinion and
being loud she was treating the kids
like adults they're high school kids
they're not school children and so you
had you had some you could hear some
guys arguing with her
and they were saying like no no like you
know blah blah and she's like well
that's dumb you're dumb and i'm like man
i would have killed to have had a
teacher debate me or argue with me about
politics in school treating me like an
actual you know like human being instead
of just
no shut up you're stupid moving on do as
i say or else she was actually talking
to these kids now her opinions are dumb
they were really bad i just think about
what would have happened if it was the
other way around where a teacher comes
out and says kids like listen you've got
to think for yourselves you've got to
plan ahead just because the media is
saying trump is bad doesn't mean he is
right then all of a sudden they're like
oh no the teacher so i'm fine with the
teacher you know to a certain degree
talking to high school kids
you know about their opinions and
allowing the kids to talk back
i mean i am too
but but you said she called them dumb
for challenging her she did okay so
that's a little bit different right
right i'm all for critical thinking i'm
all for inquiry i'm all for kids
particularly you know of a certain age
challenging pushing back on their
teachers um but when the teacher still
has a role of authority in the classroom
so if it'd be different if she said
let's engage on this issue but if she's
calling them dumb that to me indicates
that she is trying to shut down
discussion not encourage more of it i
just think she's dumb
like she didn't she didn't say shut your
mouth stop talking she she actually
engaged the student and they had like
she wasn't talking over i mean there's a
bit of like argument and stuff of course
but i'm like
man i'd love to be in a classroom where
the students are being like here's what
i think and then she's like well i don't
think me too that sounds like a good
thing for these kids to see that and to
see these these people challenging it
granted i still think maybe at the end
of the day teachers shouldn't be going
to classes to argue politics with their
students whether it's for or against
trump it wastes everybody else's time
yeah so shouldn't listen to that exactly
and so as much as i would have enjoyed
arguing with the teacher and her
engaging me i think the kids are there
to be like look we're going to talk
about math and everything you can talk
to your parents about the political
stuff
you can set up you can go in and talk to
the teacher after class if you really
want to
shoot politics and really talk about
politics right yeah sorry go ahead no go
ahead she's a chemistry teacher i don't
really think that she ought to be
talking about politics
honestly she like she squeezes in trump
stuff you know so now we're going to be
dealing with we have sodium here and of
course trump's a salty mf or that sucks
and anyway um that's sodium chloride by
the way sodium chloride or table salt
and salty like trump and i'll tell you
what
that would be funny i i i would enjoy
that you know like the the issue i had
with school was was the the callousness
the cold
the condescension
so i watched that video and i'm like man
my schools were just like shut up you're
dumb moving on
for her to be like well that's don moore
you're dumb i'm kind of like yeah but
she's talking to him and he's talking
back yeah so i think that's like one
thing we need to do with kids is treat
them like they're adults and not treat
them like they're they're stupid babies
i mean i agree with that i i will say
this one i'm surprised it's utah
if you said uh right right
boston or you know philly or
portland or something like that it did
fire her yeah she she did say a couple
things that i think warranted discipline
she said
uh most of your parents are probably
stupid or you're you're mo you're
probably smarter than your parents or
your parents are dumber than you or
something like that and she said and she
said don't listen to your parents you
don't have to listen to your parents see
that was a line that's where schools get
into trouble
where they try to undermine the
authority of parents and again that's
one of the big things that i think
may draw people to to home education is
because in many in many respects
everything that we've seen
play out in the last year
i think has been a struggle over
authority
where we see the state set itself up
against citizens who say
my job is essential if you mr or mrs
governor are drawing a check during the
pandemic
why should i have to forego my pay
when you've seen churches and local
governments
get into struggles over whether churches
can open right again an issue of
authority who
from the church's perspective who is the
higher authority is it christ or is it
caesar
and
as it relates to education it's schools
setting themselves up as a higher
authority than parents listen to us
right we know better we went to school
we have master's degree
degrees don't listen to your parents and
i think
for whatever reason parents have
accepted that that is the natural order
of things in college but when schools
start doing that with kids as early as
three and introducing them to things
that their parents don't necessarily
know about i'll give an example in in
many school districts
if a child
sort of exhibits signs of
not even gender dysphoria if the child
says
i'm questioning my gender
the schools will allow a child to
socially transition they'll use a
different name different pronouns in the
school
but then not only will they not tell the
parents when the parents come around
they will call jimmy jimmy
in front of his parents to hide it to
hide it and i think when you start to
open
those types of doors all different types
of things can come through we had a
woman on the show she was showing us a a
bunch of books the critical race applied
principle books and one of them was uh
it was called was it not my idea yeah
and it was it was azra who yeah
yeah
yeah yeah have you seen the book not my
idea i have not known it's this little
girl who looks like she's six or seven
years old and she says like one day
mommy was watching a video on the
computer of a policeman and i and then
when i came up she covers it and you
know something like that and then you
know later on
there's this they show this picture
called the whiteness contract or
whatever it's a contract for with a
devil tale and it says you'll steal from
your neighbors and whatever and then she
says you know at the end a little girl's
in the car he starts screaming i you
know no you're lying to me you're lying
to me tell me the truth i know the truth
and the mother's like oh no what's
happening okay i guess i'll tell you the
whole book was basically priming
children to
defy what their parents were teaching
them
we have seen
uh these teachers post these videos
where they say we are going to teach
your kids things you don't want them to
yeah there was the the gay men's choir
yeah that viral video
tongue-in-cheek whatever they want to
call it they said we're coming for your
kids over and over again thinking it was
funny but then they said like all the
things you don't want them exposed to
we're going to expose them to and their
friends and everything and it's like
dude parents have a right to choose for
their children what's best for them you
do not own these kids yeah but that's
that's the saying the left doesn't have
any kids they have yours
that's good yeah that's good even you
know there's a there's a show that my
kids like um it's called bubble guppy so
if you've got any parents out there who
have young children they'll know what is
what it's about and
they had rupaul
voice over a character
um in one of the episodes so the whole
show takes place underwater so the
characters are like you know mini
mermaids and fish and stuff like that
and at one point one of the characters
they were talking about getting dressed
during the day and they said yeah it's a
real drag and you could tell that you
know they're trying to let the kids the
adults in on the joke right and for me
the way i think about it
in terms of the analogy that i would use
is that
um
there's a lot of different ways to
um
to cook a steak i'll say it that way
right
but when you first pull it out of the
fridge it's not ready for the frying pan
so you can pulverize it
or you can tenderize it
and you pulverize with policy and you
tenderize with culture
and and really what the left is trying
to do in terms of their their
tenderizing
is
marinate us in these things and they
want to get the kids in as young as
possible you know because when you're
being marinated you know the spices and
you know the aroma and it smells good
and you think it tastes good
but those fibers that have been so tough
and and so
um
unforgiving for a long time are being
sort of broken down and that's how you
get people who are open to ideas
whatever the transgression is because
left is all about subversion of any sort
of social norm
um and i think that's what you're seeing
and that's the reason why they think
it's appropriate to have rupaul on a
show for kids that's you know from two
to seven years old we we covered the
story australia is building alternative
quarantine hubs with relocatable cabins
they call it um sounds like a camp right
and so the idea is that oh the hotels
weren't working so we're going to build
a hub for people to quarantine in and
we're going to have color-coded
communities so that we know what area
they're in
and we had people on super chat saying
oh come on tim we tried quarantining
people in hotels and it wasn't working
so we're just making something more
efficient and i'm like yeah that's
called incrementalization right it's
where they're like
you are now defending the camp because
it's within your reasonable boundaries
and the funny thing is i've long
explained the function of uh moral
manipulation what through what's called
um
it's resetting resetting a person's
boundaries right so the way i describe
it is imagine there's a scale of
negative 100 to positive 100 and then
you're at zero
negative 100 means you absolutely
despise a person to the point where you
would physically harm them and positive
100 means marriage in a family you're at
zero
a person's reasonable boundaries only go
from negative 10 to positive 10. you can
you can only so what that means is you
can't walk up to a random person and say
you know go hit that guy they're going
to be like what i'm no i don't know this
is right or go kiss go kiss that person
right they're going to be like no that's
that's insane but you can say
slightly in one direction or the other
like hey that person called you a mean
name or hey that person made a nice
compliment and you move them within that
boundary after a certain amount of time
in that in that space their boundaries
reset oh yeah so this is how they
incrementalize you right if if three
years ago they announced we're gonna be
building a major quarantine camp to with
relocatable cabins to house high risk
populations people would be like
but you start with the hotels and then
you go oh no the hotels are such a
disaster and then people go well just
build a place then you're right we'll
build a place it was your idea right
right right that makes more sense yeah
and it depends on who's building it if
trump was building the hotel oh yeah it
would be a very very different reaction
than
you know if if biden builds them so i i
think
i think what you described is sort of
the the overton window put into practice
for people right you know and and i
think a lot of us have been moved
in one direction or the other and you
can see
it it's almost like for some people they
they have a desire to be controlled by
the government right it's like they're
looking well well
and i found this particularly after
after people started getting vaccinated
where i would hear people say i'm fully
vaccinated but i'm double masking
while i'm riding my bicycle and nobody's
around in the woods
why would you do that well
some health professional said i should
like don't you think you have the
ability to make your own rational
decisions and
it's it's unfortunate because i think
again all of these things are linked
because a lot
a lot of us have not learned to think
critically
to to challenge authority
um you know in whatever respectful way
whatever that looks like
and i think you're starting to see the
byproduct of that you know in our
country you were mentioning you know you
had written for the root at one point
would you consider yourself to have been
a leftist at that point i've never been
a leftist no i've always had what people
would deem traditional views
i'm conversant in sort of at that point
when i was writing for the root i would
say they were more liberal than leftists
right they've definitely taken a harder
shift now i'd say over the last seven
years but you had critical thinking
capabilities seem like a smart guy and
so you are just sticking to your
principles and what you think makes the
most sense uh
when we talk about the leftists and the
socialists i don't think
you know critical thought no extends
very far no there are some people i've
met who have been fairly smart and are
just wrong but there's a lot of people
who just
i gotta pull up this story
we got a good one
from newsweek.com
socialist magazine current affairs fires
staff for trying to organize workers
co-op
how many times you need to see these
stories to realize that these leftist
institutions that magazines or media
publications they claim to be
progressive or have socialist values
and then the moment someone tries to
unionize which is like a core tenet of
you know labor rights they fire these
people you know the funniest thing about
it is is like for me they would call me
right or far right or whatever and i'm
like more power to my staff if they i
don't care or whatever like i really
don't understand why you know the young
turks did it they that story where like
some guy was trying to unionize and and
jenkins like screaming at him like slams
papers on the ground and i'm like you
guys are the progressives who advocate
for this yeah so so let me just read a
little bit and then we'll dive in
the founder of the socialist magazine
current affairs has reportedly
effectively fired several staff members
after they tried to organize a workers
co-op former employees claimed in the
letter on wednesday the letter which was
addressed to comrades by several
employees of the of the print and
digital magazine that focuses on topics
from a left-wing perspective said they
had been effectively fired by the
founder nathan j robinson who was also
authored a book why you should be a
socialist
uh is that grifting wow
in a tweet accompanying the letter
managing and amusements editor lita gold
wrote i am grieved to tell you that
nathan j robson has effectively fired me
and most of the current affairs staff
because we're trying to organize into a
workers co-op this isn't a bit i wish it
was oh wow
i don't think these you know i guess
what he said was that
you know socialism in in practice is a
lot easier or i'm sorry in theory is a
lot easier than it is in practice so
why would you fire them though
i really don't look i run a company
we've got employees and when these
stories have come up i've always thought
like i don't understand why these people
care so much yeah i mean
as someone who has you know some
experience working in the government
unionization is is a is a you know a
tricky issue because in some respect
yeah you know collective bargaining and
and you know the benefits of being in a
union
but
oftentimes it makes
doing work somewhat more difficult which
is why i think
one of the reasons you see a lot of
left-leaning um institutions fight
against charter schools is because
charter schools typically don't have
unionized teachers the teachers unions
don't have as much power over charters
as they do over government schools so
i mean i could see how it gets
complicated an employer might feel like
you know if if
their staff unionizes that they are
going to lose some power which they very
well might
but the irony the delicious irony
is that this happens all the time with
the left i think you've seen it with
defund the police yeah um i'm thinking
my mind always goes to seattle where
the mayor allowed
you know
radicals and and our kids to take over
you know part of her city
and she said you know chop chop chaz is
a summer of love
until a member of the city council
marched them to her house yup then she
shut it down like the next day yeah
you see this all of the time where it's
like
they make rules for for the little
people to follow that they don't want to
follow themselves and i think that is
one of the fundamental flaws and
weaknesses of
that particular line of thinking that
world view is that it's always going to
eat itself you know what i was thinking
i'm just like this guy for the socialist
magazine is probably and i mean this to
the right of me politically right
because as much i think
look i can i can favor certain economic
policies but
i really do think well put this way
idealistically i'm pretty left
libertarian realistically i'm kind of
like centrists like moderate liberal
type although that's politically
homeless at this point because i don't
know what makes sense but you know when
i'm thinking about a union forming i'm
like yeah i don't care if they come and
they're like hey we want all these
things i'll be like is it possible okay
i don't know why i need all that power
or why i need to be debating people if
like this is what they're looking for
now i can certainly understand when they
bring in external unions and then they
just you know can meddle in the affairs
and all stuff that i get
but i think about like january of the
young turks when he snapped at his
employees it's because they personally
want power right they're authoritarian
right they're capitalists pay more power
to them right but they're masquerading
as progressives right i mean it's the
same thing going back to blm
right they
by the end of 2020 patrice cullers had i
think she had a deal with time warner
she had amassed a pretty impressive real
estate portfolio
i mean the the leaders were living
living pretty high on the hog and it
just show goes to show you that
capitalism in our country as imperfect
as as it is and and really a lot of it
is corporatism but let's for the sake of
argument
capitalism is so powerful in this
country that even marxists can find a
market and make money off yes capitalism
is so powerful that even the socialists
are capitalists yeah yeah yeah so yeah
you you saw that so for all the talk and
whether it's them or colin kaepernick i
mean
these are some well-heeled
revolutionaries that's for sure
it's true
it's like a revolution in the revolution
they decided you know we could just make
money doing this yeah it's like the
ibram candy thing you mentioned yeah
he's not actually going to come out and
be like hey this id thing is wrong no i
mean there there's a great opportunity
for him to like
think about this if he was principled so
maybe he will do it i don't think he
will maybe he will i don't could you
imagine he has an opportunity right now
to come out and say i told you this i
told you the state would do this de
blasio is racist and he's doing it right
now and in fact people would probably be
like debasio is racist we don't like him
and and and that's why i part of the
reason i wrote the article because i i
would be truly
um
curious to see whether he would take
such a principle position or any of his
acolytes not just him right he may not
do it but to see anyone who believes in
his version of quote-unquote anti-racism
i would love to see them actually take
that principle step and say
we said that any policy that has
disproportionate impacts on different
ethnic groups is racist this one has it
we're calling it racist and we stand by
it imagine getting to stand up at a
press conference and say we warned you
yeah we begged you the government would
do this
and it is a democrat who did it to our
in our faces you'd you'd you'd have just
like look look at look at we're right
but they don't want to do it because
then they're actually going up against
their political agenda right and i mean
talk about strange bedfellows if ibram
kendy ends up being the patron saint of
the rights
anti-vaccine mandate push
right if if he is on a stage with
ted cruz
we're both against vaccine mandates we
may be against them for different
reasons yeah i mean i think everybody
would freak out at that point see that's
principle right right so i you know i'll
take it to um
joe biden he gave that speech on
afghanistan and a lot of conservatives
are just saying it was bad it was awful
then you had
clarissa ward cnn reporter on the ground
in afghanistan she's wearing the burqa
and she said
they're chanting death to america
but they're also seemingly friendly it's
bizarre and what happened a lot of
conservatives cut out the it's bizarre
part yeah and only showed the first part
it's very clear when you when you add
that it's bizarre she was contrasting
what they were saying and doing his two
different things right granted i do
think her words were you know poorly
poorly chosen but in terms of biden's
speech cassandra fairbanks a good friend
of mine said she actually thought it was
a good speech because he said things
that needed to be said like we shouldn't
be you know passing the buck on this war
we shouldn't be sending our you know
kids to go fight this
but when you're speaking on principle
you will often find that the people who
follow you get mad because they might be
speaking on tribe for tribal reasons so
you know following someone like mike
cernovich he's he's criticized trump a
lot and and the trump supporters get mad
at him like oh what happened to you and
he's like i'm being honest i'm telling
you exactly how i feel as i've always
done
so if if candy and these other critical
race theorists were actually functioning
on principle they'd have come out in two
seconds and been like no way no no no no
no absolutely absolutely and i mean i
know
there are all different types of policy
areas you know social domestic economic
political
that a person like candy could apply you
know his principles
um
if black lives matter was really an
honest slogan and an organist
organization they would plant themselves
in front of every planned parenthood in
in the black community which planned
parenthood's typically target
communities of color
and
um the same people who will say
we're against liquor stores and the
people pushing cigarettes in low-income
black communities for some reason they
don't take that same approach when it
comes to planned parenthood but
um
candy wouldn't do that because in new
york city and a lot of people don't
notice
about half of
all
um
of black women's pregnancies end in
abortion in new york city so half of all
black babies are aborted in new york
city
if you want to talk about something
that's systemic there it is but again
his his anti-racism is only useful to
their position to the extent that it
furthers their political goals so
certain things they'll say you know what
we'd rather talk about these 19 police
shootings a year
than talk about
you know street crime or abortion or the
state of urban education you know those
are those are different issues for a
different day
so i just looked it up on live action or
is it live action live
action
and they said that uh black women
account for 38 of all us abortions
that sounds really creepy it's true
that's true
that's true and so so that's why
for me i always question i i
i think like how
uh how do i put this
i mean someone really has to be doing a
number on you for you to think
that
it makes sense to give 90 of your
political support to a party
whose
central policy or one of them i'd
probably say the top three is to keep
your population at exactly 13
that that's what i was thinking when you
started talking about i'm like
planned parenthood's been around for a
long long time what are you doing 100
years something yeah and they and they i
was looking at a map from planned
parenthood and they do have a bunch of
minority area centers
and i'm thinking like i wonder what the
pers the population size would have been
for the black and hispanic community if
planned parenthood wasn't doing that
yeah
and considering 38 of all abortions
that's an extremely disproportionate
number absolutely absolutely and i mean
again that they
the the democrats talk a good game about
race
but you know where they're where their
uh policy priorities lie because every
time a supreme court nominee comes up
they don't ask them their views on brown
versus board of ed they ask them their
views on roe versus wade so that is one
of their central policies and for
whatever reason
um you know black leaders don't question
it and so i always ask people
i'd say do you think the the position of
most black americans would be the same
on abortion if it was republicans who
were pushing it
if if ted cruz was the one saying no we
need more abortion clinics in houston
and dallas
do you really think that black voters
will respond the same and i've yet to
get a good answer to that but that's one
of those things where
um for me when i write part of what i'm
trying to do is recapture some of the
territory that the left has taken um
while while some of the leaders in my
community quote unquote have been asleep
at the wheel that's a strategy for
conservatives i guess yeah just just
come out and be like you know what we
thought about it yeah they're right keep
doing it and then have people like wait
but they're racists i mean and also no
that's okay we agree that's the age-old
thing right if you want if you want
teenagers to stop doing something just
get their parents to do it and say hey
look we're getting tattoos all over our
face we're smoking you know six packs
just like you right and this oh i don't
want to be like
so
you know i i have a question um
they say that uh what what's saying that
the the path to the electorate the black
community is through the church or
something that affects you you've heard
something like that
i i have um
i think that may be an outdated
way of thinking particularly for younger
generations right right right now people
let's say
you know black voters over 65 who are
still heavily church going i could see
that so i mean you saw that in
the democratic primary where biden
captured south carolina you know on the
strength of a lot of older black female
voters many of whom are church going
the younger demographic that is a lot
less the case
so you can see that shift in the civil
rights movement from
a faith-based movement into a more sort
of secular secular humanist
uh movement blm has nothing to do and
not marxist right and now outright
marxist um so i think for younger
generations that's less the case i think
in many respects
the church has
a lot less influence in the black
community than it used to
i would actually take a more
controversial position on why that is
because
for a lot of people
they think of the black church as
primarily a service provision
organization it's basically the naacp
but with a sort of uh you know a
spiritual twist to it um i would argue
that the black church has lost a lot of
its significance because it stopped
preaching the gospel um and it's losing
people because
as
more and more black folk got you know
became more economically
uh independent and more upwardly mobile
the need for a service provision
organization went away and the church's
relevance has waned a lot since you know
dr king's age but i'm sure for a lot of
democratic pollsters they still think
that the church is the way to go
but in
50 years
i would be curious to see you know what
what that looks like is that good or bad
um which part
the the loss of influence from the
church oh it's terrible i think i think
in general
the loss of um the decline in religious
affiliation
is is bad for the country and i say it
this way and i realize people have all
different types of you know
um
political views and theological views
and i respect that
um i do think that there's a place in
the public square
for
uh religious people
um
i think that
this last
couple of years has shown that
there's an innate
need in humanity to worship something
for a lot of us politics has filled that
void yeah that religion used to to to
fill and and that's why you see
you know the the sort of political
partisanship almost take on a religious
feel
now i i would sort of make the argument
tongue-in-cheek that for the right that
looks a little bit more catholics mostly
so where you have a figure like trump
who almost functions as a pope the
things that he says to some of his
supporters
that he says from his office you know
ex-cathedra are almost like the gospel
to them
and on the left
i would liken that more to a more
protestant small p type of religion
because there's always something to
protest there's always environmentalism
it's uh racism sexism homophobia
transphobia xenophobia
and
that desire to find something to give my
life some meaning
um
you see that playing out in our in our
you know day-to-day discourse on
politics in in every other area so i
think
again as a christian i would obviously i
am i want to advance a biblical
christian worldview
um i realize other people have different
views but i think part of what makes
america america is to have that public
square
um and i think protecting that you know
you know i think of frederick douglass
he talked about the three boxes of
liberty
he talked about
um the jury box
the ballot box and the cartridge box was
that frederick douglass yeah i would add
a fourth one the soapbox oh right and i
think having an a robust first amendment
where people can come
and debate and discuss issues whether
they have the same worldview the same
political ideology or not that's
something that we need to to have a
healthy functioning republic was that
frederick douglass said that cartridge i
don't know if that cartridges what oh
they definitely had cartridges back in
the 1900s yeah
three boxes of liberty i'm not sure if
he was the first person to say it but
he's probably the most famous person to
say talked about the three boxes of
liberty right on yeah well it's a good
quote either way
man it just makes me
i think uh
you know we we
have a shared moral framework whatever
this faction might end up being uh i'm
not a christian i grew up catholic
briefly i do believe in god but um i
have my own like weird
spirituality and worldview or whatever
but i but i do have a moral framework
that is built upon the traditions of you
know judeo-christian faith
and i obviously recognize that and i
think a lot of people in america do and
one of the examples i often use is that
bill is bill maher bill mark very
clearly holds values that are rooted in
a judeo-christian moral framework
notably the right of the innocent to be
uh you're innocent until proven guilty
right which is blackstone's fourth
rooted in blackstone's formulation which
is rooted in the story of sodom and
gomorrah if there's but one righteous
person and i will not destroy the city
but the woke don't have that moral
framework no they have a lack of a moral
framework and so i was i've been
thinking about this for a while you know
about why it is that they were so
diametrically opposed and what the
factions really are and i'm like well
they don't have a moral framework at all
yesterday they can say x is good
tomorrow they'll say x is bad right you
know if enough people say that x is bad
right so there's no there's no grounded
moral framework it's literally just what
the group says is so
whereas for me i'm like i don't care
what the group says i know my moral
framework yeah yeah so so i think a lot
of what a lot of our political debates
are
sort of um
geometric debates right it's about
drawing lines the question is where is
the line going to be drawn and by what
standard so the the left definitely is
religious as i said it's just that
religion may be a religion of self
it may be you know a religion of
scientism or safetyism
the the way that the woke
um sort of framed their arguments
oftentimes in the religious you know
with religious language slavery and
racism as original sin
right um
talking about issues like reparations as
it relates to paying off a debt which
again
draws on on some you know
christian language in terms of
uh what believers believe that christ
did on the cross right to pay a debt for
sinners
the problem with the wokes religion
is that its god is never fully and
finally satisfied
so the christian believes that christ
paid
our sin debt on the cross with his death
burial and resurrection but for the left
it's god is never propitiated there's
there's no forgiveness no forgiveness
so they they believe in sin the same way
that i do right microaggressions that's
that's what it is it's you know small
sins i mispronounce your name i i
thought you were the wrong hispanic guy
in the office oh and now i have to get
you know smacked on the hand by hr so so
they believe in some of the same
principles in terms of of sin and
offense and uh atonement is just as i
said their god is never satisfied and i
think you see
that that saga that um that
cosmic saga is playing out in our
politics on a day-to-day basis it'll be
interesting in 10 years when these when
these kids either you know i hear a lot
of stories that young kids are anti-woke
because they're telling their their
teachers the teachers like who wants to
be like their teacher yeah the teacher
comes out the teacher's a loser you know
the kids don't view the teachers as cool
yeah yeah i mean i think i mean there's
always i learned this you know taking
engineering like there's always
you know you swing a pendulum one way it
eventually is going to swing back
um i'd be curious to see what that looks
like
uh you know whether kids take on a
certain anti-authoritarian strain
sometimes it's hard to see that because
when i see kids who are four and five
years old when as soon as they get out
of the car the first thing they're doing
is
reaching for their mask even my
two-year-old my now he's three at the
time he was two
we were going we would you know go
somewhere and he said dad where's my
mask and i'm like you don't need a mask
we're outside or in the park just go and
play
but a lot of our kids are being
um conditioned
um in the same way that adults are and i
hope
what we don't end up seeing is an even
larger increase in
anxiety
and depression
and neuroticism and all the other things
that we've been seeing play out for you
know the better part of the last 20
years
yeah man well we can be optimistic um to
the best of our abilities for sure i'm
i'm i teeter back and forth sometimes
depending on what's going on you know
there's optimism in you know we already
shouted at michael mouse shut him up
again he's very optimistic he says these
people are so dumb how could you
possibly be pessimistic and i'm like
it's not a bad point you know but but
zombies are dumb and a lot of zombies
can overrun a city you know so that's
true
my hope is that
eventually people's eyes will open
so whether it's foreign policy in
afghanistan whether it's
people who were saying defund the police
last year
saying refund the police this year
all these issues the socialist who's who
fires all the employees who want to
unionize that's so good
what i'm hoping is that people see
that the people that we think are elites
and the smartest people in our society
have no idea what they're doing and
honestly in many respects like we were
talking about homeschooling
nobody has done more to advocate and
advance the cause of school choice and
homeschooling than the teachers unions
they have done a way better job of
promoting homeschooling than any gop
politician ever could so when you see
how
how not just corrupt but incompetent
the leadership classes
it'll make people say you know what why
should i listen to these people they
have no idea what they're talking about
about anything so yeah right on well
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already give us a nice little smash that
like button for ian
and subscribe to the channel and share
with your friends we're gonna have a
members only segment which comes up
around 11 or so p.m so make sure you
hang around for that and go to
timcast.com subscribe if you want to
watch it let's read some of the super
chats
common sense fishing says a little
common sense goes a long way like tim
said get out of the cities may i add
also learn how to fish
i also have a fishing channel by the way
lol ian and you guys would love a day
fishing on a boat tight lines
i'd love to just go on a boat and go
fishing i'm not a big i'm not being into
them my dad used to take me fishing when
i was little and i remember their
bulging eyes and gasping for life as i
would yank them out like what was the
point of it that we'd throw it back in
the water i was like why did we do it
he's like it's fun
i don't
so we we got this fungus ice cream today
i saw an article about it i'm i'm i got
the idea cause you mentioned the bulging
eyes and gasping for life and it's like
they genetically engineered a fungus to
make whey protein interesting
and so now it's like
they made ice cream with it
and so i was i was like we got to try it
let's see if it oh it's legit
it's called brave robot and i was
surprised it's like away from fungus
this is the future they're going to grow
your meat and the petri dish i know
you're shaking your head
you wouldn't even know it if you tasted
it but once i do know it i won't want to
taste everything
yeah but but that's that's your that's
your solution and we can uh we can make
fish protein from a fungus and then you
can just eat that okay
all right we got uh we got matthew
gregory here he says my brother-in-law
passed away recently and a gofundme was
started to help with funeral expenses
since i've heard people advertise for
businesses on here any help would be
appreciated at christopher wroten
funeral expenses that's christopher
r-h-o-t-e-n um sorry to hear it man i i
wish you guys the best hopefully your
gofundme works out and uh you know
people can donate that would be
fantastic yeah
um merido's america says take a look at
the intro to the game shattered union
seems to have a lot of similarities to
what's going on hmm
all right this one's short but good mike
hockey says i'm surrounded by nuts
i wonder if that's figurative or literal
like you're sitting in a room full of
like almonds or something too many
almonds yeah
okay what is this
legum uh
leguma the gayan i think i'm pronouncing
that right fear not comrades the magical
unicorn gumdrop rainbow and fairy
marxist utopia is at hand dear leader
kamala shall lead us to the glorious
victory over vile specter of the working
class white people capitalism rape
culture cis heteronormative patriarchy
and
male privates
beautiful thank you i censored that last
part because they just
this is youtube they don't they don't
they don't you know
they don't like naughty words
all right let's see crandall logan's is
amazing news to share mr pool i have
just gotten my first handgun the taurus
judge revolver it is a three inch barrel
in the three inch chamber it is
chambered in 45 long colt and two and a
half to three inch 410 bore shotgun
shells i am so excited i too am a uh
owner of the judge
and um the governor i have both how are
you how do you feel about guns you have
guns
um
i believe in the second amendment
um
you know and i think
every law-abiding citizen should avail
themselves of their rights so i'm i'll
say this i grew up in new york
i had a very very different relationship
with guns firearms
growing up
um when i was coming up gun meant
someone is trying to kill somebody else
right
rarely did you hear about people
shooting a burglar or a robber
um my wife is from texas she grew up in
a very different culture as related to
guns
and my views have evolved
over the years but i will say this
i think as many
you know as i do on many issues
i believe in more responsibility for the
individual
and i take my family safety and security
as my primary responsibility
so whatever
you know tools that a person wants to
use to make that happen
i'm i'm all for it's a good way to put
it yeah
or uh
uh kia reyna sounds like she agrees with
you ian she says tim it almost it's
almost like the biden admin did this to
justify the us going back in i don't
know but it's hard to believe the
government oversight is this bad
i you know but biden's so incompetent
maybe that's that's the grand conspiracy
was they were like we need to be
believable when we when when we script
so bad we have to go back in
biden will be believable the republicans
will call him demented for months then
when afghanistan fails no one will
believe it was on purpose
i don't think it was on purpose i think
biden is just
not with it he's not there and there's
no there's no there's no central force
in the decision-making process
so uh there was uh what i think was
millie who said when they said why
didn't you evacuate people through
bagram air force base which is a
military installation and he said i was
ordered to guard the embassy so somebody
told them
to do something else that's probably
biden
yep
all right let's see
james m says blow back tell that to all
the afghanis we abandoned and our allies
who align our protection being willing
to fight evil makes us stronger
man
it's a it's it's a tough situation some
people are saying i'm shilling for the
the deep state by saying that there's
sometimes reasons for intervention which
i'm like i'm not necessarily saying it's
a good thing i'm fairly
anti-intervention and then others are
saying like no we have to defend our
allies yo look i'm not the arbiter of
morality and truth i'm just telling you
what i think and you can tell me i'm
wrong all day and i'm fine i think you
made a good point about
about how if we just sat here and never
got involved that some some
authoritarian government would surround
us and yeah we basically be starved out
from siege warfare economically and so
like we gotta
we gotta instill what i wanna do my goal
is to instill these values of freedom
that we have in the united states across
the world to every human to give them
all access to running water internet
electricity transportation food
shelter
it
i don't know that we can do that
politically we definitely i don't
definitely don't think we can do it
through like democrat republican
uh
party politics
it's like you gotta do it on an
individual level and then and then show
people that extrapolate the individual
process
i don't know
i don't know see but what i heard you
say just now you talked about you know
food shelter running water i hear
um resources not necessarily the values
of freedom because someone will make the
argument that a central government
right a socialist government would
provide those things
but so they don't i don't necessarily
see
having those resources
be
being provided in every country
as necessarily being linked to
our understanding of freedom i i think
they can be
but
someone will as i said make the argument
that you don't need a free market
economy you don't need liberal democracy
in order to provide water food and
shelter to your citizens and in fact
they may say you can provide those
things more effectively through a
centralized plan government than you can
you know free enterprise yeah we'd like
to use the military to build
solar-powered water condensation across
the world in like desert tribes and
cities and houses and stuff like that
but forcing freedom i mean
good point how do you do that
all right we got ted too he says active
military the other day we did a brief
exercise on care for casualties followed
by an entire day of sharp slash eo
training soldiers were essentially told
they think like rapists and any pushback
was steamrolled oh wow
creepy
i don't like that yeah uh
taka nokage says i can't stop thinking
this was on purpose not incompetence i
don't know
all right hanlon's razor yeah yeah for
sure especially with biden he's proven
he's not you know
swing dip says just saw your nollie hard
flip rewind video i had no idea you
could shred like that when will we see a
tim pool skate video at the compound i
mean we in one of the vlogs i did a hang
ten hard flip and uh you can look hang
10 hardflip up on youtube from my buddy
brett novak's channel and this is this
is the craziest thing there's a video of
me skateboarding when i was i think i
was like 18 or 19. that's from like it's
one of the first videos ever on youtube
and it had like 5 000 views for a decade
and now it has like like half a million
or something it's a great video because
people keep getting suggested it and
it's just a video of me skating when i
was like a teenager wow and it's not
like the greatest skateboarding in the
world it's just a few like little you
know silly tricks i was doing that's how
the value
producing a lot of work if you want to
be successful because the stuff
eventually if you keep making work one
will break you through yeah and then
they go back and watch your entire body
yeah that's true
well you can go watch that i guess but
you know we'll we'll get some skate
videos at some point i was uh i was i
was actually skateboarding the other day
i've been rollerblading quite a bit
something new something fun but i was
skateboarding the other day too because
some of the guys out here we got more
people working and so we've got some
skateboarders and it's a lot of fun
all right let's see
mack 3n says just wanted to say that
your stream yesterday was good but it
hit the feels hard myself and a lot of
my army buddies are having issues with
the way the withdrawal happened keep
doing what you're doing your work helps
people more than you know hey man really
appreciate it yeah well we we we called
out to people we knew had experience we
you know jack bosobic uh he served but
he wasn't in afghanistan and forest was
an army ranger in afghanistan and i was
like these would be perspectives that i
think would be good you know to have on
and talk with so i talked to forrest
after the show we were hanging out
outside and talking about post-traumatic
stress and he had a very insightful
comment about it that a lot of
soldiers in combat
combat's the most real thing you're ever
going to experience everything else
dies away and you just see what's
happening you see your buddy freaking
out and you push him on the ground and
get the job done and then when you come
back here and you see people talking
past each other afraid to be honest
the crap like this is the fake and
that's that has this impact on people
that people the civilians don't
necessarily know how real
life can be yeah
so i empathize with you yeah mike
sullivan says with all due respect tim
you say that at least we are finally out
we now have twice the troops in the
country did a month ago if 10k americans
are trapped how many more do you see in
the next month you are correct yep
what so i'll rephrase i think it's good
that we're making moves to get out and
we should but the problem is biden
screwed it up so bad
i it almost feels like it's on purpose
to be completely honest because now
you've got people being like
like okay okay can we at least stabilize
it and then
leave maybe in a month or a couple
months it'll turn into forever it'll
turn into another 20 years you know
maybe what happens is biden resigns in
disgrace or is 25th amendment and then
camaleris is like i will not be the one
to see these innocent people suffer and
then you know you get more troops and
more troops and more troops
we've got the militant islamic caliphate
now is is building up there what are
they called the the caliphate of
afghanistan or something yeah that's
what we did to iran
littletails farm says tim our i am
somani eggs hatch in a week we will
record the process for everyone to see
on our channel thanks for all the good
vibes you send we love the show and our
big supporters of you and your crew
thank you very much we have three baby
chicks
um
two of them are leghorn rhode island red
mixes oh
i that that's margaret and roberta
roberto's rhode island red he's a
rooster
and then we have
it's an easter egg or chicken but i
don't know exactly which one
and so there's a little tiny brown chick
which is very cute and then there's two
yellow poofy with like one's got like a
little uh like cool haircut it's got
like black hair and the other one's got
like a little brown spot
and and we've got uh 12 i think we have
11 more eggs in the incubator right now
starting a new cycle which is a really
bad idea because winter's coming which
means we're gonna have to keep them we
have to build a heated indoor space for
that boy but that would be fun yeah not
hard to do and we could film it and
it'll be fun and chicken city is gonna
end up with like what is that gonna what
is it gonna give us like 21 oh gosh no
no 24.
yeah lots of chickens i love the way
they run they're so cute they follow
each other little dinosaurs
so the chickens that we originally
raised like wobble we bought
when they were a couple weeks old so
they never really liked us yeah you
could hold them but for the most part
they'd you know get away from me and now
they're adult chickens and
there's only one vanessa she'll walk up
to you and she'll hang out and you can
actually very slowly petter the rest of
them just like scream and run and
rooster will run up and go like in your
face
but
because we hatched and are raising these
now they're probably gonna be very very
human friendly yeah and they'll probably
hang out like walk up to you and like
you know look around i'll be cool
chickens are great they're funny and
their food
that is true
all right the last of my kind says had a
scary moment i live just outside the
city limits of houston and city workers
went door to door passing out vaccine
info but i overheard them reporting over
radio which houses were vaxxed what
interesting wow wow i mean i'm not
necessarily surprised but
all right nathan o'connell says with the
executive branch in shambles do you
think the next move is to quickly pass a
bill through to nationalize police force
any form of ron wrong think will get you
in a camp or in jail last ditch effort
to hold onto power coming up next
they need a lot more before they can do
something like that
maybe the delta variant maybe the was it
lambda or epsilon the epsilon and then
lambda maybe there's a major lockdown
and then they say oh no we have no
choice
it's hard in america man we got it we
got a first amendment and a second
makes it very very difficult dude
decentralized police is legit that was
something i learned living in chile is
seeing the national cops all over the
place because they don't have it's every
everyone's a fat your cop is a fed chili
so if the president says
do it
the entire national police force acts
terrifying yeah let it never happen
john curry says tim a bunch of
businesses in nyc are suing nyc over the
vaccine passports they are not all just
accepting it yes we did we did go over
that the other day and i'm glad to see
it that's a good thing
hankin around says tim you're glad the
troops are out at at the risk of seeing
an american assassinated every day for
30 years
there's so much nuance to this
the americans should have been evacuated
immediately even trump has said it trump
had a plan he said first you get the you
get the americans out you get you get
our allies out you take the military out
and you blow up the bases
that was not done
so now
we're in this predicament where yeah i
guess we have no choice but to send in
military right good job biden so look
i'm saying biden coming out and saying
we should leave is a good thing whether
or not he actually can pull it off is
entirely different
so it i i can't blame the guy and say he
did it on purpose i can only say he's a
bumbling [ __ ] who made everything worse
and he can go down and go down in
history as being just that a bumbling
[ __ ] and that's all he will ever be
although maybe it was on purpose i
honestly don't know
if i'd evidence suggested was i'd
absolutely be talking about it
says my older brother was supposed to go
to college tomorrow but his flight from
southwest got canceled without warning
they didn't give a reason as to why oh
yeah
we have seen many weird things happen
with flights so we book gas all the time
you know we have someone coming in every
day
we had one instance where
uh someone checked into the flight got
to the gate with a ticket and they said
you're not checked into the flight you
can't get on this plane
we had one person whose flight was
booked
oddly for the same time his return and
departure were the same time
and then we saw the mass cancellations
from spirit and american airlines
stories like this we hear a lot i'm
almost wondering if they're just like we
can't sustain this just like arbitrarily
boot people for whatever reason wow
there's a fuel shortage there's a labor
shortage yeah so don't be surprised if
you see more and more and more
what what was it the the green new deal
wanted to get rid of planes
yeah i think that was more convenient
and cows and cows yeah farting cows
all right
profit position says the soccer fields
in afghanistan were used for executions
and public stoning by the taliban food
for thought when you think about that
soccer star wow
das ruse says professor d in the house
my favorite contributor on fearless yes
respect
das rouse says thoughts and prayers for
uncle jimmy yeah what's that all about
um so uncle jimmy who's um
jason woodlock's sidekick on fearless
um
came down with covet a couple days ago
so he's been
he was at home
um he he did a segment on the show
probably i think last week
but then he he uh fell ill yesterday he
had to get rushed to the hospital but
thankfully he's back home now oh cool i
heard he's doing better
and um you know him with locking
constant communication so
definitely praying for uncle jimmy
hoping he makes a full and speedy
recovery and and his two sons who i
think are also quarantining with him
right now right yeah hopefully they're
all okay yeah yeah he's a little bit
older so
all right blackrock beacon says as you
said tim unequal enforcement of the law
was acting as a sorting mechanism vax
mandate for government workers military
and police is too if they won't stand up
for their own rights they won't disobey
orders to protect yours it's a purge
yeah that's what's worrying
all right
along the watchtower says if i have to
pay to speak on this channel isn't that
our government in a nutshell
i don't know is it pay-to-play yeah
maybe yes technically
seth hauser says on a scale of one to
ten how bad do you think it is
in general
seven
eight
ten being the worst yeah you gotta
define it well you know what honestly it
is for me personally
this is one i've got probably top top
point zero zero zero zero one percent of
humans on earth right now yeah yeah
yeah and i should correct that i should
correct that because what are we talking
about are we talking about like 10 being
the apocalypse and one being utopia
because then we're at like a two
basically yeah yeah and two was my first
thought was two right it's like it's bad
so if we're talking about american
politics
like where 10 is like a breaking point
then i think we're at a nine or a ten
yeah yeah but does that mean we're going
to be you know then there's another
scale after that so honestly right
specially catastrophically two out of
ten yeah
well no i mean we've got so much tech
war
war sucks pollution pollution ocean
acidification but we can massive drought
we can withdraw the carbon from the
atmosphere and repopulate the ocean with
iron fertilization there's a lot of
technology is really awesome right you
know you know what bugs me a lot about
the the climate zealot types is that
they're missing one of the bigger
pictures in this
in the pollution with the pollution is
that it's the destabilization of the the
ecosystem balance
meaning it's it's not about whether the
planet gets you know too hot it's about
whether or not we've produced you know
0.1 percent more
waste product of this particular element
which is causing a change in density in
this area which then creates a ripple
effect and so what happens is they talk
about like oh climate change
conservatives are like you know what are
you talking about
and then we have people like chris
martinson on and he's like he's a doctor
he's a phd and he says people have
noticed there's no more bugs hitting
their windshields they did a study and
found that over 20 years substantially
less bugs are in the air hitting
windshields which suggest to die off in
the population potentially there's also
ocean dead zones these things will have
a massive impact so pollution plays a
huge role
all the waste water coming out of the
rivers and the ocean creates pockets of
death just nothing there
and so that means fishing what we're
seeing now with fisheries being over
fish is jellyfish moving in now people
are eating jellyfish
yeah that's right the bugs apparently
the neo-nicotinide pesticides are
messing with their ability to like use
their infrared or whatever their their
thing their but that's not considered uh
their communication abilities it's not
considered pollution it's a pesticide
but it's doing damage like pollution
right if it's if this is actually the
culprit which it seems to be
we got a uh null enol says this man is
leadership material oh
agreed
all right
along the watchtower says do schools
cover the cost of masks
let's go a question that's a great
question i feel like i read somewhere
that some school districts were
requiring masks
as like part of their uniform policy
and if that's the case some may cover
but parents definitely have to buy their
own uniforms that's for sure
yep yep now they're i think one texas
district made it part of the uniform
yeah to bypass the the bands or whatever
yeah
matthew hunter says ivermectin is fda
approved under the name stromektol stop
saying it isn't fda approved that is
medical misinfo yes i must correct
ivermectin is not fda approved for
treatment in covid ah
ivermectin is a is an essential u.n drug
for a lot of reasons so that's why i'm
just like i'm not here to give you any
medical advice but that that is a good
correction
iron mechanism approved for kovid for
treatment that's that's that's the big
issue i guess and we've had the debate
we've pulled up the studies and the
studies are we're not at that point yet
so whatever you want to believe about it
don't take your morality your medical
advice or financial advice from me and
i'm not a lawyer either or any youtuber
but i appreciate the correction that
yeah that is important
all right let's see
jeffrey paris says first love you guys
and delano left us today remind me of
the ori priors from stargate oh really
they are uncompromising and won't
hesitate to destroy your life for the
slightest disagreement how can we ever
reconcile with them
i don't know how many people know what
the ori are from
stargate
if you have groups that that um
won't negotiate
yeah what what did aggressive
negotiations i guess i don't know
sebastian smith says first time super
chatting i have a friend in army
artillery who just got orders to go to
afghanistan with no deployment date not
leaving anytime soon
interesting
yeah i wonder if they're just going to
bolster the troops in afghanistan this
is the excuse trump drew down our forces
from fifteen thousand five hundred to
twenty-five hundred and now biden's got
his excuse to send in tens of thousands
of more
here we go again
to do what though
like just what are we doing in south
korea i don't know yeah what are we
doing in germany
chilling preventing the spread of
communism is that really the mission
i don't know
i guess man
all right
ryan says in regards to tim's point
about some people may be more
comfortable in a sleeping bag under a
bridge freedom like a shopping cart no
effects is a real state of mind yeah
have you guys ever been homeless for any
short period of time or medium length i
slept in my car for a while it was
incredibly no rent payments that was
like
wow but it's illegal
yeah i wasn't if they'd come and knocked
on my window i would have been i once i
once uh stopped in a parking lot outside
of a skate park and i woke up surrounded
by cops that their guns are on wow and
their lights in the car and i'm like i
was i was in a dodge neon
and i was wearing like normal clothes
and then like i mean i put my hands up
and they walk up like unlock the car and
i unlock the car and they open it and
they're like get out and i get out and
they're like what are you doing and i
was like i fell asleep
and they were like why and i was like
i was skating and i was chilling in my
car and i fell asleep and they were like
okay well you can't be here and i was
like i'll leave and they're like okay
and then they all like okay i was like
what happened
like yo i'd park on the side of the road
uh put the driver's side
seat down and then cover myself with a
blanket so that they couldn't see human
yeah when they looked at it yeah that
worked
it's crazy out there but man the sense
of freedom is is palpable there's
nothing like it you can sleep in your
car in walmart
walmart parking lots yeah really they it
is still illegal but walmart allows it
okay uh it's called what is it called
boondocking they do because they know
that when you wake up you go inside
walmart to buy your stuff okay so
they're like we got more than enough
parking lot so people actually will if
like people in like vans and and trailer
like and like rvs
will be like well we can't find the you
know a campground or whatever let's just
pull into a walmart walmart's like
awesome especially if you've got like
five people and you're here in your
camper you're coming in for everything
that's great for the trees food yeah
for them but it was a i was told it was
a hotel lobby that tried to make that
made it illegal because they want you to
pull over and go inside and go to the
hotel
yeah right let's uh
get the youtube to force jump our super
chats and then confuse us
eddie says
when immigrants love the country more
than its citizens then you have a
problem i value the usa because it's
given me everything so i think when the
afghan people rise up they will truly
value freedom just like the immigrants
in the us compared to their homeland i
hope so yeah interesting
bradley says there is an entire
generation of afghans that grow up under
crony capitalism they are now getting
their first taste of sharia law if they
want a free country they will have to
forge it themselves
i heard that definitely
johnny knoxville says i don't think it's
the real genuine actual tim the far left
will try and make life so miserable for
those not vaccinated that they cave in
and get the shot
exactly yeah like even even with the
lawsuit in new york city how long is
that going to
take i mean probably weeks at least
i'll say months months yeah so you can't
go out to eat you can you can you can't
go anywhere yeah and you can wait months
for a lawsuit to go through
so again i'm curious to see you know
whether the vaccine mandates the vaccine
passports which a lot of people called
early on by the way and they were called
conspiracy theorists
whether that red pills a lot of people
i think at the very least what it'll do
is that it will increase the contempt
that a lot of people have for their
government because it's some people will
say you know what i can't afford to lose
my job i can't make that choice off a
principal
but while i'm getting this jab or i'm
showing my passport or i'm showing my
papers
it's going to make me hate the people in
charge right and i don't think we've
really wrestled with what the long term
consequences are for that
you know best case scenario
it makes people take local politics a
lot more seriously
worst case scenario it could end up
radicalizing certain people
and making them go from saying i'm
switching from one party to the next to
saying i want to be done with all types
of government um all together yeah i
think a lot of people are starting to
feel that way yeah
all right ill machiner says ian check
out saffrodite it's similar to obsidian
it goes from looking like charcoal to
clear with light how do you spell
saffronite s-a-f-f-o-r-d-i-t-e
cool
that sounds really cool actually
i gotta go to rock store jake willmott
says i gotta recommend you have lucas
botkin from t-rex arms on your show i
believe you have a great conversation
with him he has shown interest in being
on your show before we will check him
out that sounds cool
all right
let's see
rafi bosk says you guys should look into
biogas you can make your own gas out of
food waste for cooking or even running a
generator oh cool yeah yeah i've heard
about that that sounds pretty cool
i'm i'm definitely a big fan of reuse we
were talking about building a hanging
garden on the property a hanging garden
yeah what does that mean like so we can
stagger it and make it oh you mean a
vertical garden indoor vertical hanging
stuff indoor wear i don't know
these are the ideas that get thrown
around at the castle well we they do
have those like greenhouse things you
can buy yeah oh yeah we
and then we can do because i'm all into
this biogas and like just total
revolutionizing 21st century
homesteading
yeah man
i am down
trevor conley says tim i'm from flint
michigan i've heard you say the water is
possibly fixed here it is not fb memes
compare gen 6 to taliban thoughts
i think those are absurd yeah um and
i've had people super chat being like
they fixed the flint water already you
know it's it you stop saying that i'm
like okay well i don't know i don't live
there but i'll tell you this
it should have been fixed a long time
ago
what was the what caused it oh it's a
long story yeah lead pipes so uh let me
take you back on the journey i'll make
the story quick the population of
detroit is shrinking but the water
infrastructure remains the same size
that means the share of
maintenance cost per person is is is
getting higher as more people leave
so if you have 10 people in a house they
each put in 10 bucks to pay their 100
you know plumbing bill and then five
people leave everyone's share doubled
now they're paying 20 bucks so that's
what basically happened in michigan as
people were fleeing the state
it ended up
you ended up with some of the highest
water costs in the country
so flint was basically like why are we
paying all this money for detroit water
when we got this river right here switch
and the river was filthy
there's a lot more to it than that but
you know then you ended up people
getting like lead in their pipes
they had lead pipes so the corrosive
water was stripping the lead out and
then kids were drinking it and it was
affecting their iqs and then you had
legionnaires disease because the water
was really bad yeah
yeah i did a uh uh um
a chemical chemical a chemical element
analysis and there was some weird
element we found a lot of when we i took
samples from the river a couple samples
and then we found something i can't
remember which it was it's been years we
didn't find lead was it selenium by any
chance
it might have been i don't remember it
was a it was it was a like we saw like a
huge spike in one particular element
that we thought was really weird and we
didn't expect because it wasn't reported
and so the the the researchers were like
we don't know if we're confident that
this is correct because it's kind of
anomalous yeah we'd have to do it again
and i'm like i'm not flying back to
flint to test more water so i had to
climb down to the river and it's like i
was slipping and i was like trying to
get the water
did they replace all the lead pipes is
that what when they finally said it's
out of the system is
i don't know i don't know we'll have to
uh you have to you know read up on it
let's just do uh we'll do uh one more
here
all right let's see
pat monet says my band used to park at
hotels and sleep in the van overnight
and then wake up in the morning and eat
the complimentary breakfasts no one ever
noticed when you're a broke band you got
to do what you got to do
that's right a lot of people do that all
right my friends
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and and do it for ian yeah there
is there is a sad ian waiting for your
like today but what do you like when you
hit that button
if you hit it with love then i feel it
that's right let's send those waves uh
and go to timcast.com we're gonna have
we're gonna have a bonus uh members only
segment coming up it'll be up around 11
or so p.m this should be a lot of fun a
lot to talk about and you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally at tim cast
delano you want to shout any social
media or anything else website um
again people can can read my commentary
um at the blaze
uh i'm on jason whitlock's show fearless
with jason whitlock uh three times a
week uh you can check out his um youtube
channel for all the episodes
and you can follow me at delano squires
d-e-l-a-n-o-s-q-u-i-r-e-s
on twitter and instagram right now and
and and jason's awesome yeah
yeah absolutely amazing guy i'm a big
believer in chaos theory so tap the like
button leave a comment because they have
resounding fractal consequences that you
may not see even in your lifetime but go
for it anyway yes see one comment could
turn into an argument which turns into
ten thousand comments of people arguing
people could create genres of careers
based off of the inception of that
comment so if you feel it
actuate it take it make that
take that statement you gotta do it you
heard it ian you heard it from me and
you have to listen to him you guys are
more than welcome to follow me at
sourpatch sourpatchlidslyds on twitter
as i continue my journey to have more
twitter followers and sour patch kids
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you